Terrance Hayes
“Four Premonitions of Migration”
To grasp the inextricable ghosts
riding you
into an inexplicable future,
you must place your lips
to panel thirteen
until you taste something human
in the colors of the dirt.
To suit present life
you must revise
“The crops were left to dry and rot.
There was no one left to tend them,”
to read:
“The cops were left to cry and shoot.
There was no one was left
To defend them.”
To perceive the ghosts
in this particular picture
you must imagine the orb
above the field
is your eye waiting for bones or buds
to erupt.
But let’s just head uptown,
someone there
is throwing a child named
Jacob Lawrence a party.
It is fine to walk
without speaking to each other
if we are walking
beside a pair of tracks
or a river
with no burning bodies in it.
I wonder where the land
of the freedom really is.
Not Ohio, maybe Canada,
Guadalajara,
someday maybe the Congo.
Outside
it is always tomorrow.
At some point, I’ll be boxed
and stuffed in a suit
I currently mistakenly believe
I’ll never be caught dead in.
2015, 2040, some other year
that’s a fistful of syllables,
then in 2115
whoever
discovers panel thirteen
will assume the orb above the field
is an apocalyptic spaceship.
Migration can,
of course, be spatial,
as well as mental, spiritual,
and temporal.
Could black people be incarnations
of Time?
Yes, because Time, like the Negro,
carries
the past as if it was a rucksack
holding the Sunday dress
a mother and daughter walking North
sewed
from the suit of a corpse
left to dry and rot in Dixie.
Each of the techniques useful
in the transferal of dirt
requires work against gravity.
The dress
seems to get heavier, I imagine,
though each night
when the ladies stop
to inspect it beside a shy campfire,
they find it is the same old dress
only a bit less clean.
They do not sense you and me
in the dirt overshadowing the fields
or know that dirt,
by definition, is made of history.